[Music]
foreign
movie dinosaurs do get judged more often
than other fictional monsters they are
analyzed for their size power and
ability to instill fear and so here in
this video we will do the same ranking
the most powerful and deadliest
dinosaurs to have ever graced the big
screens so let's get to it boys
and number 10 we have the
quadrupedosaurus a quarter what the
dinosaur Reptile from 65 the movie The
Apex Carnival that was seen near the end
of the movie and also outside the cave
in the rain it was a quadrupedal animal
imposter with long full Limbs and had an
armored skinny skin and a deadly skull
with a terrifying jaw full of conical
teeth it was around the same size as a
d-rex which means it was powerful but it
was only as fast as a normal human being
and also not the sharpest tool in that
shed nevertheless it still makes it on a
number 10 spot due to its size which
makes it powerful at number 9 we have
the indoraptor the indoraptor was
portrayed in Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom as a hybrid dancer that was
extremely powerful and intelligent in
terms of physical abilities the
indoraptor is shown to be very agile and
stealthy it has razor sharp claws and
teeth and that it uses to attack and
kill prey obviously in terms of
intelligence the interrupter has been
demonstrated to have been very highly
trainable and capable of following
complex commands meaning it has a very
high IQ for the answer it also has
Bulletproof Skin which makes it highly
resilient to bites as well
number eight The Tarbosaurus the
trapezoids from Speckles the movie is a
carnivorous dinosaur that lived in what
is now Asia around 17 million years ago
during the late Cretaceous Period and is
often referred to the Asian cousin of
the T-Rex the main character in the
animated movie grows up to become the
leader of his pack measuring up to
nearly 12 meters or 39 feet with a 4
feet long head and was capable of
killing an old T-Rex called one eye
number 7 the Tyrannosaurus Rex so this
one is from the Jurassic movies there
were a few T-Rexes that were featured
there each were over 40 feet long and
more than 15 feet tall while the exact
strength of a T-Rex in the movies is not
quantifiable it is generally depicted as
being able to take down large prey with
ease and to withstand considerable
damage to itself Rexy the biggest from
the Jurassic World movies was one hell
of a beast but she still lacks when
compared to the upcoming ones
number six Spinosaurus the spinosaurus
in Jurassic Park 3 is seen as an
enormous Beast 50 feet long and 20 feet
tall with powerful jaws and sharp teeth
capable of crushing bones and tearing
flesh apart inch by inch from any
dinosaur it can get its hands on or its
jaws on it is also portrayed as being
highly intelligent and adaptable capable
of tracking and capturing prey using its
senses and problem solving abilities one
of the most memorable moments is when
the spinosaurus fights a T-Rex and
eventually winning the battle after
breaking the T-Rex's neck therefore
taking the sixth place here in this list
number five the Giganotosaurus the
Giganotosaurus clone had large crests
running down the top of its brow and
down half of its skull giving an
appearance of an indominus Rex in a way
the Clone specimen measured around 15.5
meters or 50.9 feet or 51 feet let's say
and stood about 5.5 meters or 18 feet
tall and also weighed 9 tons furthermore
the Clone specimen is said to be capable
of running at speeds of up to 30 miles
or 48 kilometers per hour it was able to
beat the T-Rex 65 million years in the
past and also again in the present day
as a clone specimen
number four the vastusaurus Rex or the
v-rex as seen in the 2005 film King Kong
the v-rex is Skull Island's Apex
terrestrial Predator Skull Island
virex's face little competition for the
title of the top Apex Carnival despite
their size of around 50 feet long and 18
feet tall they can put on a surprising
burst of speed for short periods of time
reaching speeds of up to 25 miles per
hour of 40 kilometers per hour in
Pursuit Of Prey they are armored and can
take a great deal of damage like it's
like a T-Rex on Armor and steroids
fighting for dominance against King Kong
himself so yeah that's why they are on
the fourth spot
number three the indominus Rex the
Jurassic world movie indominus Rex is a
dinosaur hybrid like none other it is
portrayed as a highly intelligent being
and a very powerful Predator with a
variety of unique abilities it measures
50 feet long or 15 meters and 18 feet
tall or 5.5 meters tall and it also
possesses Incredible strength and
durability as well as speed
because it was bought Raptor as well as
having a highly developed sense of smell
eyes and hearing it also had camouflage
abilities and the ability to communicate
with Raptors it is highly adaptable and
resistant to various forms of attack
including gunfire and other weapons and
it can also easily beat a T-Rex in
battle
number two the Carnotaurus so this one
is from the Disney movie aptly called
dinosaur the carnotaurs are fearsome
here and they are portrayed as reddish
bees with long tails sharp teeth and
short horns and also very tiny four
limbs they stand around 20 feet tall and
appear to be 60 feet long highly
Amplified versions of the real life
specimens in the movie The iguanodons
which were more than 10 meters or 33
feet long were seen as being half in
size as compared to the massive Predator
so due to its massive size it would be
able to defeat the smaller indoor rags
and hence being on the number two spot
and number one from movies we have
godzillasaurus the precursor to the
G-Man himself he takes the cake even as
a dinosaur godzillasaurus differs from
other theropods and that its posture is
more upright similar to that of a human
being and it drags its tail on the
ground it is much larger than any other
theropod species standing 12 meters or
40 feet tall owing to its erect posture
and also said to be 20 meters or 65 feet
long and 60 tons in weight gunfire and
even rocket launchers were ineffective
against him and only battleships the
massive guns were powerful enough to
draw blood and weaken him so you see why
he is the deadliest movie dinosaur ever
and so the bigger ones than him and now
Kaiju dinosaurs and those are on a
different video so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam